hi
my name is igel and welcome to our
google session
i've been looking forward to doing this
presentation
even before a year ago
this is going to be one of those
sessions that you're going to remember
even though you don't work with this
technology it's quite a unique
case which affects all of us
today i have one of my customers
ulrich christensen and maybe you can
tell me a little bit about your cell
phone right
yes hi my name is ulrich christensen i
am the
principal infrastructure engineer at
oncology venture and i'm going
tell you some about the stuff that we
have at oncology venture
in terms of the things that we're
running in google cloud
and using the citrix products
and uh my name is e joe brocker i'm a
system engineer with citrix in the
nordics
mainly in denmark and i've been working
on this case for
almost a year now and i've been really
looking forward to telling you a little
bit about what we do at citrix together
with
google cloud so a little bit about the
agenda today
so first of all i'm going to talk a
little bit why google cloud why
citrix and why this collaboration is
working so well together
then i'm going to talk a little bit
about the future of citrix which is our
digital workspace
and then we're going to hear a little
bit about how oncology venture our
customer
uses this workspace in in in actually
creating their solutions
and supporting their team all around the
world and then we're going to hear a
little bit about this
very very unique case about how you can
actually
scan for cancer in google cloud using
citrix technology
and at the end of the session we have a
little bit about where oncology venture
is
moving from here into the future
together with google cloud and citrix
systems
and then we have some links to some of
the technology that we're starting it
which if you want to try out some of the
technology by yourself
so a little bit about citrix and google
cloud why
are we collaborating with google cloud
well first of all
we both have the same identifiable
core features about reliable and trusted
around security so citrix has been for
many years one of the trusted companies
when it comes to building a secure
digital perimeter about your application
deliveries especially within
virtualization
we've been one of the few
pioneers within virtualization
app deliveries in a secure manager on
many different types of
types of os so it's been a really
incredible journey
for citrix for over 25 years now and
then
as we move into the future together with
google we're looking into
analytics and data inside so we've
always been an expert at looking into
the application usage within our users
using our technology on a citrix
platform from
uh endpoint uh back to the server farm
and then we're looking at how can we
together with google cloud and
transform how we collaborate in teams
and nothing has been more testing for
all of us during this
growner virus in working from our house
and still
maintaining high productivity and doing
a lot of collaborations in a digital
world
so it's a natural fit between google
cloud and citrix because
at the core we share the same goals and
the same values
so this is a partnership
a perfect fit and it's been ongoing for
many years
we started out a long time ago and we
have a
few for the last five years introduced a
lot of technologies
in google cloud yes we are working
together with all other cloud preventers
but we have a very very rich feature set
with google cloud and there's very very
little that we don't introduce
into our portfolio that is built for
running in google cloud and i can just
one of the main name brands that citrix
has for many years is the netscaler now
it's called an adc
it's a front-end load balancing and it's
at the core of
most of what we do and if you look at
the top 500 companies around the world a
lot of them use
the adc features for load balancing
secure gateway and many many other
things
so we have we have really invested into
this partnership and as you can see from
this slide
there's a lot of technologies where we
adapt where
google is going and adapt it into our
google technology
into our citrix technology and one of
the things that we've built is also this
sd van which creates a security
connection between your
your future in the cloud and down to
your on-premise
environment we're also known for our
single sign-on feature set especially
around
adc and i know oncology venture is
looking into
to using this so we have really
been a single sign-on company for many
years and we continue to build that
as as google introduced their idp
solutions
uh more and more into to
enterprise business another thing that
we are known for is utilizing high
graphic loads so for example the signers
who needs a lot of gpus to do rendering
in high-end graphics uh most of the time
when you're working in a simple
framework structure you don't really
need this
heavy gpu loads and it's increasingly
expensive
especially around medical research where
they're
using this gpu to to for example look at
high resolution
x-rays or biological
scans so these the definition on
some of these scans are very very high
and one of the things that we are using
within google public cloud is the
nvidia gpu acceleration where we can
actually take a machine
and share it amongst many users so solo
like you can book
a schedule a time where you need this
enormous solution to do all your
rendering
and thereby you can save a lot of money
as a company so very very
large investments that we're gluing
together with google moving forward so
there's no doubt about it this is a
at the core what citrix do this
partnership with google
when we look into the future we've
always been known to have
a very good app deliberation we have
been very very good at presenting
content to remote users
around the world and remote when you're
looking at where
everybody right now is working we're
working remotely
we're doing this session remotely so
it's at the core what citrix does
but one of the things we've always been
known for is also
supporting a lot of devices so in the
old days when you needed to run
an enterprise solution and you had some
of the users using macbooks or
chromebooks
you would need citrix to virtualize this
enterprise app
to push it to any device anywhere so one
of the things that
we've been doing for many many years is
multiple device support
and just to give you a a a glimpse into
that
raspberry pi is becoming a mature
enterprise product and we are actually
supporting
with our workspace client to raspberry
pi
which in some scenarios and you might
laugh about it but i went to the
hospital the other day
and in the heart uh cardio award they
actually had a small raspberry pi for
monitor just showing the
the remote ekg of the patients walking
around the ward
and that was being presented on a
raspberry pi hooked up to a monitor
so it's really becoming any device
anywhere
uh and any application available and as
we look at application we're moving more
and more into
sas application not necessarily having
virtual applications we're also looking
at how we can do
all the things that we're known for
security analytics
and signal sign-on with local apps which
are pushed out alongside perhaps
virtualized app or
even sas apps and and around that we
have built this secure digital perimeter
based on these 25 years within the
enterprise space
where we supported a lot of the largest
companies around the world
in my own country i can't go to any
hospital in denmark
without coming into a doctor who knows
about citrix and knows
when i tell him i work for citrix he
knows exactly what it is because it's
the first thing he sees when he locks
into a computer
so that trust is really something that
we would take at heart
and when you hear about ulrich's story
within healthcare why he chose google
cloud
there's a very interesting perspective
about the two technologies being heber
compliant but i'll leave that for all
right
so what we're doing with the digital
workspace is
enhance the experience and productivity
so that means that we are
constantly monitoring the change in
location the user has so we can do
something about the performance
and maintain a high performance uh from
from the users
having to do his job we're also using
we're looking at the way that we
collaborate so a lot of users today
have too many apps and when they need to
make a decision they need to log in to
different application and then you open
them mail and then write a response to
that
so those were that world we're trying to
compress into what we call micro apps or
microservices
and being able to take a lot of content
switching between applications
into this micro apps world
and that is something that we've taken
the lead on and actually designing these
and we have full interaction with other
vendors out there
including google so when you're looking
at using
enterprise application running in google
cloud we're able to take that data and
say
okay 80 of the time you just need this
information and that information
collaborate together and then have this
approve or disapprove or
deny a transfer of funds or so on so
simple actions
is something that we don't want to do
within our workspace
so how does it look what we are actually
uh delivering
with google platform so we we we have
you can divide citrix into two world one
is the control plane
and one is the workhorse behind the the
curtains so to speak
our bdas our vdas are the ones who are
actually doing the heavy
lifting and doing the presentation that
uh the control plane is just doing the
introduction of the users and what
rights the user have and all the single
sign-on but then the workload service
and all that i will show a little bit
more about how that's running and works
in
in google cloud we have a
citrix access control so for example if
you're on one location
you can save things locally on your
device but when you are outside on
another location
or outside your zone for example if you
in europe and you work out of the us
when you're in europe you're not allowed
to save on your local device
so the whole access control thing we
have actually integrated into g
suite which is a very
where you just take the security part of
g suite and lift it to another level
using access control and this is what a
lot of
our customers they really appreciate
about citrix that they can say well you
have one user scenario
when you're working inside the company
and you and access to these shares
and then you have another scenario when
you're working on a different location
or even borrowing somebody's device to
do work
and of course we support the story with
our citrix workspace app
for all of the google devices that you
can think of
so even down to uh chrome
chrome based devices uh android devices
and and so on we integrate our
enterprise device management into the
citrix
g suite solution
so the citrix resource location on
google cloud i won't go so much uh would
i rather have ulrich talk a little bit
but what it actually does is that you
take
the the users are creating a session
which hits the workspace at the gateway
services
the control plane simply says well you
have the right to this
and then it introduces you into the
workload service
via these cloud connectors now the cloud
connectors are crucial technology
when talking about a hybrid solution
where you both
coexist on-premise and you work in the
cloud
so that's where the cloud connectors
come in and though
it actually defines which applications
should be presented to you which file
shares
which cloud-based file shares you should
have available
and it presents the best vda for that
desktop that you're actually running but
i'll
recover it a little bit more now this
solution
from oncology venture i actually talked
to ulrich over a year ago
and i was so fascinated by the solution
uh because it can actually change
people's lives we've all had people who
are
affected by like and what he told me was
sounded like science fiction but i
believe we we've pulled it down to earth
uric so maybe you can tell a little bit
about oncology venture and the solutions
that you've built
yes thank you very much for that um
so let me start by introducing the the
company oncology venture so
oncologyventure is
a medtech company based in copenhagen
with employees in the us all the way up
or down
the east coast of the u.s we have
developed a platform
that can predict the best treatment for
cancer patients so
our platform is called drp and is based
on the full transcriptome
of the of the messenger rn or the
messenger rna
that combined with tumor data from other
patients
we have created an algorithm that can
predict the treatment that will benefit
the patient the most so
our employees work on many different
devices
anything from windows machines to mac
and also on mobile devices
so we spent a great deal on support
before we introduced
citrix to our employees
people they're also working in different
time zones so the support could be
quite difficult so we
decided to offer this standard solution
the standard desktop
with all the right tools and all the
right applications that they needed
so it was easy for them to get things
done
by making this centralized solution we
also managed
to secure our files uh y'all just
mentioned that with the digital secure
parameter
because no of no files left
that are our own data center or the
google cloud
data center so
um that made the solution very secure
uh and and we also heard about before we
had some some key challenges if you can
say that
um so we experienced some
poor some poor performance
um with some other vendors cloud
cloud vendors uh and we all we we
actually started to look into this
on-premise solution
but we rolled that out quite fast
because
the initial cost to build own data
center
uh with all that you know what what what
that took with cooling and all that
that was just way too expensive so we
started to look into
another solution and we ended up with
google cloud and citrix because they
gave us the features and the performance
that we needed
um we also had limited scalability
before we
introduced this um the citrix and google
cloud 2 on called adventure because
we didn't have any where to build it
actually we also had
many different cloud solutions we had
file solutions
um and they were kind of scattered all
over the place so we didn't had any
standard or any structure in it so
and with this kind of data that we
handle
we need we have very strict security
security requirements so we needed to
step up our a-game to meet those
requirements
with citrix and google cloud um
we immediately saw that we could get
those
uh features and that performance that we
needed
so we were also able to implement uh
all the security thing that the security
things that we also needed
um and with the partnership between
uh citrix and google we were able to
scale
this solution on on on google cloud
so i want to talk a little bit about
um the workspace app did you all
mentioned that just
earlier so
we rolled out citrix workspace app to
make it easier
for our employees to get access to their
data
so we have people sitting around the
world working on our solutions
and also we have people traveling so we
wanted to give them
the best and most easy access to all of
our applications and
and all to our files also another thing
was that
when we had new hires they were
productive from day one
all they needed was the workspace app
and then just logged in and they had all
their apps and all their
files right there right in front of them
so that was a lot easier for us
so if you look at the solution as a
whole uh it don't
mention this also so um
all of the other users are sitting on
their own device
and all they have is the workspace app
now they connect
from the workspace app through the
gateway
which is in citrix cloud from the citrix
cloud
the gateway connects to the
sorry the citrix cloud connectors and
that
and the citrix cloud connectors uh
communicates with all the things that
you have in your back end that could be
your active directory and all your
server vda so all
all the workloads where your
applications are
and all your files are so
with this solution we were able to
give people secure access and also be
able to
scale up the environment as needed
because sometimes we had
people coming in consultants working on
different projects
and we could easily spin up some extra
workloads in
in google cloud with a machine creation
service
that was introduced by citrix about six
months ago if i remember correctly
uh and we could get asked and we could
get
access to these uh
external consultants right away from day
one
so why did we choose the workspace
well for us the most important thing was
it
it gave us easy onboarding so it was
very easy for us to onboard new hires
and also when things changed if we got a
new application
it was easy for us to push that out to
our employees around the world
it was also easy for us to get
external consultants access to our to
our own system
another thing was that we got a lot a
lot less
uh support from our employees
and we had everything in one place so
all our applications and files
could get you know people could get
access to those
files and applications from one place at
the same time
it kept all of our data safe
so with citrix we can provide a much
better service
to our users and to our to our partners
which i think is a key element if you
want to stand out as a professional
company so why
citrix in google cloud so we started out
to look
at it as an on-prem solution and
because of the cost we just didn't go
with that
so we had to buy a lot of stuff to get
that rolling so we looked at different
public clouds and we ended up with
google cloud
as the best fit for us the reason were
that
google cloud was very simple to get
started with
and for us it had the best performance
one other thing was also the citrix
google partnership
and citrix was really helpful uh they
were very serious about the partnership
with google as well
so as i mentioned before citrix released
machine creation service
uh which made it a lot faster for us to
manage and update our image and being
able to push out new applications to our
your employees one
other thing that
that the partnership came up with was
something called auto scale
so with auto scale
we only spin up the resources
that we need in google cloud so
when we don't have any need for any
resources
our auto scale is going to turn off
the machines that we're not using so
over i tried it on for about a month and
in course at that time
i believe we saved about 40
on our cost on resources in google cloud
so if you're thinking about moving to
a public cloud it's it's a very good
feature to have because it's going to
save you a lot of money
so so ulrich so for example a lot of
people
go to public clouds they're afraid of
the cloud economics because
once you spin up a machine you know the
economics
it's just the the the meter is just
ticking
so help you control your
you could sleep better at night knowing
that if nobody was using the system
the the workload service would be shut
down and machine creation service
gave you the agility is that right
that's
that is that is correct so when
well since we have users in different
time zones we
we almost always had you know users on
the system
but sometimes you know we had more than
other times and we there the auto scale
feature
scaled up um the number of workloads
that we have for the users so
as soon as the number of users you know
when they locked off the system
auto scale automatically scaled down the
number of workloads
so it's simply just uh remove the
workloads
which means that you don't have to you
know pay for those resources anymore
so that saved us you know quite a lot of
money actually
so and with machine creation service i
remember you told me that
it actually retains the metadata of the
vms that you have in google cloud
so when it needs to spin up you know
that it's the same
type of vms that actually gets spun up
which is
really cool yes not only that uh it
keeps the metadata so
it also um firewall
firewall rules exactly so when you spin
up
like let's say they if you spin up like
four new workloads
those workloads will get the same meta
uh data pushed on to those vms
which means that you don't have to go in
afterwards and
you know um and do all the firewall
rules
uh for those four bms because
the system already knows that so it's
it runs pretty much vital by all by its
own
so you don't have to go in and do
anything
uh you can actually pretty much do all
of it by itself
so that's that's actually one of the
very unique features about running this
system in
in google cloud so good question
so tell me about the the cancer scanning
the really exciting thing that you're
doing
so as i mentioned before uh we also run
our dlp
platform in google cloud
so well we used to run
the drp platform which is
our our drug response predictor
and we were able to run
i would say about 8 to 12
samples at the same time and
we knew that we wanted to scale it up
and be able to run more at the same time
so
we decided to to look into could we run
these
samples in a containerized environment
because if we could do that it would be
a lot easier to scale it
up and down so actually we had a project
with about 1500
samples and it took us about
two and a half to three weeks to run
those
samples and i believe that
in the new on google cloud if you want
them
run them there we can do it in probably
two or three hours i guess so going from
two and a half weeks
three weeks to two three hours for the
same
amount of work so that's a
that's a big deal um so
we actually went ahead and built this
solution on google cloud and citrix has
been a big part of that as well
uh to secure this application as i
mentioned before
this kind of data we need to lock that
in we have to make it safe
so citrix has has a big part of it
has a big part in it so we
introduced citrix adc to the solution
and we're going to talk a little bit
about that um
so but before before you do that
so a hospital gets a cancer sample from
a patient
they submit it into the cancer scanner
and the cancer scanner
opens a container for that one sample
it has a a scanning mechanism of
what kind of drugs has the best
opportunity to cure this kind of cancer
and then a report comes out the other
end saying
dear doctor i would recommend this
treatment or this treatment has this
kind of
probability of success yes this has the
least success
criteria so it's both best success and
the success
is the report that comes out at the
other end you can
you can say that so what we do is one
once we get
the end result we we we put in
um uh sample
into the you know it first it has to go
through
our own wet lab and then we uh once
it once once that is done uh we can put
it into
the system that we have our drp system
and the end result from the drp system
is a report saying that which drug
will benefit the patient the most
that's um that's what we get
and before you can do it very very few
and now we just scale it up
uh in the cloud we can we can
scale this up we can we we can now run
um
hundreds maybe thousands of samples um
at the same time so yeah it's
quite big a deal so and yeah and the
part of the google cloud that you have
loaded your solution into
is hipaa approved is that correct
yes that is correct so that's that's
huge that just based on that you you can
uh
go through all the fda stuff and say
well we're running it in a heba approved
location you know the fda we're we're
talking to those guys right now so um
okay say no more tell me a little bit
because
another heba approved product is the
citrix adc
and that's one of the reasons you chose
it
the the 80s the the reason why
we looked at the adc is one of the
things is that we need to
make sure that the application
itself is safe
it's secure and the data that it's being
put in there is safe
okay so and also we need to
have some kind of user control so we use
the adc
uh to ask different idps
it can be from a company
it can be from google it can be from you
can even use facebook if you want to but
just you know so we can
control um you know that
which users have access to this so if we
have someone that
that comes up to us and say you know we
would really like to
uh you would like to try your you know
your
your drp system we can
we can uh we can integrate with uh
with what whatever user idp that they're
actually using
so yeah that's one of that's some of the
reasons why we
came uh we chose the citrix adc another
one
is that uh citrix has uh
introduced something called the citrix
ingress control
now each um
we have a number of what is called parts
on kubernetes running our web
application
so we have a
cpx citrix adc
cpx load balancing the different parts
on kubernetes and then we have a vpx
a citrix adc vpx that are load balancing
the different cpx's
uh and what happens is that if
let's say we run up uh four
or five parts the
citrix ingress controller automatically
puts the configuration from the second
tier to the first tier
adc so if you have
something that breaks and the
and the cluster needs to spin up a new
part
that uh that change will automatically
uh be configured to the adc
so that uh that gives a great way to
deliver
a very reliable service
yeah so basically you can
it can handle whether you spin up 20
containers
or 50 containers or 2 000 containers
it will still manage e-container as a
separate environment and it will make
sure that your medical data is
protected within that container yes
super so
what's next for oncology venture
so what we're looking into now is
actually uh
giving pharmaceutical companies
access to this technology so they can
test their drugs and see if they
if that works on their patients and also
giving
easy access to hospitals and doctors as
well
so that's the next step for oncology
venture
and with that i'm going to hand it over
to john for
a short session recap so for those of
you who
feel brave enough based on the testimony
from ulrich today about his solution
we have some links for you to to take a
look at
especially around the adc and the
ingress mode to control
multiple containerized solutions
and then take a peek at the machine
creation services
which allows you to rapidly deploy a lot
of servers within google cloud
so i urge you to take a look at these
links and our outer scale technology
could really save you money when using
google cloud
which is the best way to adopt cloud
technology within your organization
if you have any questions don't hesitate
to reach out to ulrich and i
our emails are in the link and thank you
for joining us today at this
special session